guillermo tiene un tanque de vidrio de
26 litros por supuesto esta es la
capacidad del tanque primero quiere
poner algunas canicas en él todas del
mismo volumen eso es importante luego
quiere llenar el tanque con agua hasta
que esté completamente lleno si usa 85
canicas él tendrá que agregar 20 puntos
9 litros de agua muy bien cuál es el
volumen de cada canica muy bien esto
esto es una pregunta muy interesante
vamos a vamos a plantear el problema
nosotros sabemos que el volumen que
ocupan todas las canicas vamos a denotar
lo como ve y una un subíndice que
representa las canicas ese volumen si
nosotros le sumamos el volumen que ocupa
el agua entonces debe ser igual al
volumen total del tanque verdad de subte
de tanque entonces en realidad nosotros
no sabemos cuál es el volumen de cada
canica pero lo que sí sabemos es
y el volumen total de las canicas será
85 veces el volumen de cada canica
verdad entonces tenemos 85 que
multiplica al volumen vamos a escribirlo
así al volumen de una canica que todas
miden todas tienen el mismo volumen así
que si multiplicamos por 85 nos da el
volumen total de las canicas y si
sumamos el volumen del agua en este caso
agregamos 20.9 litros de agua esto debe
ser igual al total al volumen total del
tanque que en este caso es 26 muy bien
así que tenemos ya una expresión para
poder determinar el volumen de cada
canica y quizás esto es muy complicado
vamos a denotar todo esto con una sola
letra una variable y digamos que sea la
de la variable c&c de canicas
y vamos a seguir solo con un color para
que esto sea un poco más ágil entonces
tenemos la siguiente ecuación 85 veces
sé que es el volumen de cada canica más
29.9 que es el volumen del agua que
hemos agregado es igual a 26 así que hay
que resolver esta ecuación para hacer y
eso lo podemos hacer restando 20.9 de
cada lado de la igualdad del lado
izquierdo se cancelan y del lado derecho
tenemos 26 menos 20.9 por ejemplo 26
menos 20 serían 6 y 6 menos punto 9
serían 5 puntos 1 verdad entonces
tenemos 85 c es igual a
5.1 muy bien y ahora lo que hacemos es
dividir de ambos lados entre 85 por lo
que tenemos que c es igual a 5.1
dividido entre 85 y bueno y bueno esto
se ve complicado de calcular mentalmente
así que vamos a sacar una calculadora
aquí tenemos nuestra calculadora vamos a
hacer 5.1 dividido entre 85 y nos da
como resultado 0.06 muy bien tenemos
0.06 ese es el volumen de cada una de
las canicas así que la pregunta es cuál
es el volumen de cada canica es de 0.06
litros ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con la
siguiente pregunta dice cuánta agua se
necesita si guillermo utiliza 200
canicas muy bien así que lo que podemos
hacer es representar la cantidad de agua
que necesita en función de las canicas
por ejemplo la cantidad de agua en
función de las canicas
lo podemos calcular de esta expresión
necesitamos el volumen del tanque menos
el volumen de las canicas pero el
volumen del tanque son de 26 litros y
hay que restar el volumen de las canicas
en este caso vamos a agregar aquí
tenemos 200 canicas verdad así que hay
que multiplicar o bueno vamos a
escribirlo así el volumen de cada una de
las canicas multiplicada por la cantidad
de canicas que estamos agregando y ahí
tenemos la cantidad de agua que
necesitamos en función del número de
canicas que hemos agregado verdad y de
hecho ésta es una función lineal para
determinar la cantidad de agua verdad
aquí lo único que estamos haciendo es
calcular el volumen total de canicas que
tenemos y cada digamos el volumen total
es el número de canicas multiplicado por
el volumen de cada uno de ellos muy bien
entonces en realidad a nosotros nos
interesa saber la cantidad de agua que
necesitamos si usa
200 canicas esto será 26 - 0.06 por 200
canicas muy bien y esto es fácil de
calcular verdad esto sería como 6 entre
100 y esto sería 2 por 100
así que simplemente nos quedaría 6 por
12 6 por 12 y eso es el perdón 6 por 2
son 2 ella estaba adelantando me esto es
6 entre 100 y esto es 2 por 100
simplemente nos queda 6 por 2 que son 12
muy bien
así que simplemente calculamos cuánto es
26 menos 12 y esos son simplemente 14
así que la respuesta a esta pregunta es
14 litros de agua se necesita si
utilizamos 200 canicas